welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka
the guy who always comes through with a
breakdown in the rick of time
puns are getting worse but i've been
doing this for seven episodes and
in this video we're going to be breaking
down the latest rick and morty entry
go tron jerry sis jerisis rickvangelian
probably pronounces that wrong as well
but it's filled with easter eggs hidden
details things he missed as well as
several callbacks to movies and tv shows
now this episode was accidentally leaked
on several streaming services
as it was posted instead of rick
dependent spray there's clearly been a
lot of panic behind the scenes
and my last two breakdowns were actually
blocked by adult swim for a couple of
hours
which was quite annoying fingers crossed
that this one doesn't go down and though
the episode is heavily inspired by
voltron
the title of the episode actually pulls
from its japanese counterpart
neon genesis of angeline throughout the
episode the family meet with four other
versions of themselves
army watches the quote-unquote gotrons
are made up of five pieces
which combine with five other larger
combinations in order to make an
ultimate version
called a go go gotron the word go
actually means five in japanese
so this all ties it together and it's
like poetry
they rhyme now we start off with rick
morty and summer traveling to boob world
we learn it was originally just a
celebration of boobs
but due to protests they've had to
rebrand as a female empowerment
experience
which is the only reason why they
brought summer along boob world was
actually first mentioned in rattlestar
galactica but like this entry we never
actually got to go there
however when we meet the four other
families that are brought in from the
multiverse we discover they actually all
went there as they didn't come across
the goltron ferret like our trio do at
the start
in the cockpit they find the corpse of
the blue pilot and this is a reference
to the show go lion in which the blue
pilot
also died in episode six a bit of
retconning brought him back
but it's hilarious that they link it to
that in order to show why one of the
gotrons is down
rick says he's gonna give morty the
choice to either go to boob world
or to hook up the gotron to the ship and
though morty chooses the former
rick steamrolls ahead with his plan
anyway later on the gotron pilots end up
trying to bribe morty with boob bucks
for boob world
and the fact that he turns them down
when he wanted nothing more than to go
there
shows how far he's come this is where we
get our first voiceover
which we learn is due to some parasites
called voice ovarians
ovarian now this is clearly a nod to
goodfellas which gets several easter
eggs in this episode
and throughout its summer and morty
gives several monologues much like how
henry hill did in order to describe how
the mafia worked
summer becomes addicted to being rick's
sidekick and she says that she knew then
and there that she wanted more
this is pretty much paraphrasing henry's
first introduction to the mafia in
goodfellas
and like him the character has a rise
and fall now shout outs to tvtropes.org
for pointing out that summer actually
ends up developing a personality
disorder
throughout the episode which is called
acquired situational narcissism
because she enables rick throughout the
entry she quickly becomes his favorite
and this makes her start to act against
the rest of the family
the website also pointed out she later
developed something called toxic friend
influence
which a lot more simpler sounding in
real life this is someone who peer
pressures you into doing things like
staying up late
watching leaked episodes of rick and
morty and also disliking videos
now unfortunately her enabling rick to
do more and more makes him turn on her
and she eventually snaps out of it when
rick fires her too
now from here we go to the title
sequence and as always this is the part
of the video where i ask you to thumbs
up
and subscribe if you do this you'll
enable me and you'll actually become my
favorite
until i have no use for you and i just
cast you to the side
to go hang out with other youtubers like
philip defranco
and maybe tatty westbrook or something i
don't know is she cancelled this week
or is she good again i don't know but
cheers for the likes
yeah [ __ ] now whilst the titles were
happening we learned that rick simmer
and morty were collecting the other four
gotrons
morty pulls his boot off and sniffs it
and says that it smells skeletony
clearly meaning that they found the
other gotron pilots dead
and i wouldn't be seen dead in that
costume are you having that now it's at
this point that beth mentions the giant
incest baby
who we last saw at the end of rick
dependence spray this baby ends up
popping up later on in the episode as a
way to fight the go-go gotron
and we learned that summer called it
naruto another nod to anime and manga
summer says that they get the family
they get and not the one they want
which morty later brings up and says
that a great leader once said it
summer is often overlooked and in rick
dependence spray the president gave the
scientist a nobel peace prize
even though it was summer who came up
with the baby idea this kind of brings
the arc of that full circle
and shows that she can have input and
that the family do value here
they managed to convince beth and jerry
to commit them to nimblenug
which is where they fight against the
giant kaiju not only is this of course
playing on the trope of the characters
in voltron constantly fighting giant
beasts at the end of every episode
but also the film pacific rim in that
giant monsters arrived on earth through
a portal in the ocean in order to
destroy the planet
and humanity had to arm up in massive
mech suits in order to fight back
in the post-credits scene we learned
that these monsters are actually
normal-sized bugs
that travel through an interdimensional
doorway in the hopes of giving humanity
a cure for aids
however their clothes are stripped as
they're turned into giants
and we're unable to understand them so
it just leads to us attacking them
and they then defend themselves the
family traveling to the gotrons is
pretty much exactly how the suit-up
scenes happen in voltron
and at first they zip-line down which is
what happens in the show
they then travel to subterranean tunnels
and emerge from locations around the
world
this includes a volcano the ocean an icy
cave
and also a waterfall because morty is a
little punk though
he comes out of a car park and who knows
maybe the theories about this season
being the origin story for evil morty
are indeed right rick once more uses the
bottle gun
which has now appeared three times in a
row in the series perhaps hinting at
this one being the real one
whilst all the episodes before which
didn't have it were in fact decoys
they arrive at a parody of the golden
gate bridge in san francisco
and are beaten at first but they combine
together to make a mega gotron
and they defeat it by just hitting
buttons they also form a luminous energy
sword
which is from the show now after beating
the bug we can see rick drinking alcohol
again
and the dribble forming around his mouth
it was thought that rick might have gone
t total in the season
as there were several points early on in
which he wasn't drinking
the dribble hasn't really been there and
the character also hasn't been burping
all the time
but this changes up in the episode as he
gains more and more power
rick is obsessed with making an even
bigger gotron
and mercy summons four other families to
pilot the other ferrets
just before this though we see the
outside of the house and you might
notice on the front garden and driveway
that there's a big crack around it
this was first spotted all the way back
in rixie business
before reappearing in a rickle in time
we aren't still 100 what's going on with
it
but leave your comments below and let me
know what you think now the five family
meeting feels very
similar to the wedding which opened the
godfather whilst
everyone has dinner on the outside and
the band plays inside the rick's talk
business
rick is referred to as c137 which is the
version thought to be from the main
timeline and the other versions pull
heavily from the godfather
we have one which looks like don
corleone called big fat rick
hot head rick who is a nod to sunny and
little ricky wrap it up
who's playing on fredo in the godfather
al pacino played michael
however he also played score face in
another movie
which is what ricardo montoya is
referring to
later on in the episode when rick has a
masters empire he sits in a cockpit
which looks a lot like the hall from
tony montana's mansion
rick wants to bring everyone into their
universe and initially hothead rick has
an outburst during the deal
which is similar to the scene in the
godfather when sonny has won during the
narcotics meeting
he's almost killed when trying to get to
his car and in the godfather
sonny was of course gunned down whilst
he was outside his
michael's wife was also murdered in a
car bomb but hot headrick survives
and he goes off to plan his revenge they
pull in yo-yo rick instead
and we watch as a montage plays out in
which the ricks kill the gotron
pilots the montage feels very similar to
the ending of the godfather
when several characters were all
assassinated at once and we watch as
this goes from a fun adventure
into a crime family one they end up
providing protection for earth
and killing lots of kaiju along the way
in mafia type hits
these include curb stomping one against
tadam which is an execution style that
several hitmen have carried out
there's also a bit in which they make a
kaiju to get its own grave with another
bug beside it
this could be a reference to tommy's
death in goodfellas in which he was
forced into a grave alongside his
brother
in retribution for the bat's murder they
also get a giant centipede
and put lots of buckets of cement around
its feet before throwing it into the sea
we then see a jerry murdered as a
warning and yo-yo rick
ends up getting moved around so that
he's not killed summer ends up demoting
morty and this is a nod to the godfather
and god for the two
in which freighter was slowly demoted
and put in charge of family issues that
didn't really matter
he wasn't respected and because of this
he ended up betraying his brother
which led to his debt rick slowly gets
worse and worse and he embarrasses
everyone at a party
which is when the characters get the
idea that he's slowly turning evil
now feel at this moment is a nod to the
god for the two namely the lavish party
when michael realized that fredo had
betrayed him
michael ended up kissing fredo which
wasn't not to when judas kissed jesus
before his betrayal outside mori comes
face to face with the gotron pilots
who look exactly like how they do in the
anime and they want morty to betray his
family from the inside
he says that he won't because summer is
his sibling which juxtaposes how fredo
betrayed michael
even though he was his brother they
accused the family of cultural
appropriation
and whilst this is going on hot head
rick ends up attacking the party
and killing most of the people there
beth gives morty money and says she has
to turn her back on him
which is exactly what paulie said to
henry and goodfellas before he cut him
off
henry two showed up in a beat-up suit
but that's because he was a coke addict
and not because he got in a car crash
now moving on things start looking up
for summer
but they ended up bringing in
replacement families to help the
organization
and none of them respected her rick
slowly spiraled into his own addiction
of gotron
and he decided to recruit outside the
family namely kendra who we can see
survive the crash
in a blink and you'll miss a moment we
can see that she's reading a magazine
called gundam
which has an rx78 head on it which is an
easter egg that links to the anime
gundam
rick gets rid of the whole family and
though they talk about killing summer
they welcome her back with open arms she
tells them that the government ended up
capturing the giant incest baby
as they wanted to use it as a weapon
they wanted to see if it would respond
to her
and though she was meant to discipline
it she trained it to love and then
escape
this is a trap that's appeared in a lot
of monster movies where they force a
woman in to communicate with a beast
have been in several films such as king
kong sputnik
but i think that this version is
drifting slightly on shape of water
due to the military outpost design morty
knows that the gotron pilots will betray
rick in order to take the robot
and they attack him out in space rick
says say hello to my little me
whilst firing a gun that looks like him
and this is obviously a nod to say hello
to my little friend from scorface
he's shot but when it looks like things
are over the family arrive on the baby
to take the pilot out
we see several of them sucked into space
and even one that's choked to death by
hanging
outside of kendra the blue is the last
one to die which juxtaposes the opening
of the episode in which it was the first
yes i like saying juxtapose because it
makes me sound smarter than i
actually am now kendra is killed and the
family saved rick
but rather than accepting that he caused
a lot of problems
rick just stops talking about the
gotrons summer says the giant bugs that
are still running rampant can never kill
her family
but we see that jerry is left outside of
the house to fight them
now that ends the episode and yet again
i'm kind of torn on the season so far
it started off really well but i think
over time they've kind of lost direction
though the episodes are all pretty fun
and their parodies are spot on i kind of
feel like they're almost combining too
many at once
i was speaking to superhero nexus about
this earlier in the week and there's a
lot of times where they just take random
things
and mesh them together this can lead to
the episodes pulling in one direction
for some parts
and completely different ones in the
others which to me feels
totally disjointed now that's not to say
it's bad but i
am really torn on this one though i
think it's pretty strong on the most
part they're just not hitting the same
heights that they were in earlier
seasons
still though overall you know it was fun
and as always the jokes worked really
well
i think we're just kind of in a rut at
the moment where they take some movies
parody them make rick go a bit bad and
then have him turn back to the family at
the end
hope that everything sort of comes full
circle and though i don't think that
this series will be the origin of evil
morty
i would actually enjoy it if that turned
out to be the case gonna be weird seeing
how the whole thing wraps up as we are
heading towards the last three episodes
for this season
and hopefully they've saved the best for
last as i do want to see some bangers
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the episode so comment below
and let me know
we are running a competition right now
and giving away three mcu box sets on
the 30th of july
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode we picked the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one on
screen right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of last
week's episode which will be linked on
screen right now
we pointed out all the easter eggs we
could find and the callbacks to movies
so it's definitely worth watching if you
enjoyed that entry without the way thank
you for singing through the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace